[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في هذا الموجز من قناه الجزيره
قالت الشرطه البرازيليه انه تم تعبئه قوات
اضافيه من ولايه عده في البلاد لدعم قوات
الامن في البرازيليه ياتي هذا بعد ان
استعاده قوات الامن البرازيليه السيطره
على القصر الرئاسي ومقر البرلمان والمحكمه
العليا اثر عمليه اقتحام نفذها مؤيد
الرئيس السابق جاهير بورسونارو رفضا
لتنصيب رئيسا للبلاد
توجهتها المحاوله الانقلاب لمن شاركوا في
عمليه الاقتحامه بدوره وصف الرئيس ما جرى
بالاعمال الهمجيه واتعهد بمحافظه
في المقابل لرفض الرئيس البرازيلي السابق
جاين بور سونار والتهامات وقال في تغريده
ان المظاهرات السلميه جزء من الديمقراطيه
لكن اقتحام المباني العامه يمثل تجاوزا
هذا وادنا الرئيس الامريكي جوبيدا ما وصفه
بالاعتداء على الديمقراطيه وتداول السلمي
للسلطه في البرازيل وقال ان المؤسسات
الديمقراطيه البرازيليه تحظى بدعم
الولايات المتحده الكامل
كما دنا وزير الخارجيه البريطاني ما وصفها
بمحافظه تقويه الديمقراطيه في هذا البلد
وقال ان الرئيس البرازيلي وحكومه يحضيان
بالدعم من المملكه المتحده وعبرت بدورها
الخارجيه الفرنسيه عن دعم باريس لدا سيلفا
وحكومه ضد من وصفاتهم بالراغبين في
التشكيكه بنتائجه الانتخابات
في السودان انطلقت المرحله النهائيه
للعمليه السياسيه بعد شهر من توقيع
الاتفاق الايطاليه وقالت الاليه الثلاثيه
الميسره للحوار اذا الاتفاق حاضر بدعم
كبير من القوى السياسيه والمجتمع الدولي
هذا هو رفضت قبل الحريه والتغيير الكتله
الديمقراطيه لاتفاق الايطالي وقالت انه
مرفوض بشكله الحالي ويتعهدت بتحريك الشارع
لاسقاطه وذكرت الكتله انها اوقفت اللقاءات
غير المباشره مع مجموعه الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي
لاوكرانيا الحق الكامل في استهداف الرؤوس
في شبه جزيره القرمه من جانب اخر علانات
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها قتلت 600 عسكري
اوكرانيه في اكرامي
في المقابل نفى الجيش الاوكرانيه تصريحات
روسيه وقال ان الجيش الروسي لا يملك
القدرات الكافيه لتوجيه ضربات تلك الدقه
الى اللقاء